welcome to this video this is different
right this chest tube after a really
long time not playing i started i
entered eternity a bottom I'm a late
entering here looking couple of minutes
it's a two minute tournament some guys
got 12 points so quite them a
substantial difference to my score let's
see exchange queen seon you know I have
a very this window is the rating minutes
get rid of that and I'm not sure I have
it a very big screen is very big a need
to adjust that it's really a bit too
much okay let's see I hope that I can do
something against the week sepan and now
I've got night c5 to d3 taking be three
here we go yeah get the exchange anyway
okay
covering me five days pinned on the C
file so yeah I said your pins he didn't
listen maybe Roxy for GC g six made yep
I didn't double right i forgot this
again Here I am really you see the Sun
kind of tournament two minutes chess
better let it be quick here going for
some direct the text okay let's get the
Queen into the game here's some
development issues okay let's see this
is at least dangerous he takes comintex
Walker 7 h-7 will win this is also
dangerous hard for him to come on our
cut the h-bomb
hmm
let's see my can maybe take ya decide
already believe my god for I can first
take right don't need to promote
immediately I don't see a maid at the
moment
how the matin hmm that's that's one okay
got him in the middle of the board yeah
all right well I'm i decided to do some
chest cube action just as a bonus for
the Christmas days and these games are
usually more for entertainment value to
help you enjoy some quicker games okay
let's see em skype from India about
2,000 rated and some I will try to get a
direct attack may be g5g form this is
some slightly risky but the play will
play of an option let's see what he's
doing
I have not castle because of it maybe I
should consider Bishop g4 actually
trying to provoke h3 and then return and
then g 5y 4h three years son and move I
very modular coming let's see how you
spend enormous time at least so this is
a mistake I believe
I have a very quick opening of the g
file now and i get i get the King out of
out of the bill by little castling long
and now i need to get rocks on the g
file this i don't really believe our
queen g4 can maybe play Queen G from
what are you doing here yeah okay Quincy
form I can do that right a bit slow slow
thought process let's get the King out
of checks only 675
this is this pin by the Queen as a
problem it cannot really move the bishop
and is spending no time not really no
Queen trade first we look at five now
yeah it's difficult to play position
let's get the book yeah this I have from
the screen here is far too big the Sun
doesn't help with my speed
okay I'm sorry I need to I need to
readjust this a bit sorry if the
recording is a bit strange at the moment
I cannot I cannot that's a shame oh I'm
sorry for that i cannot really adjust
the recording area okay let's see how I
don't get into any who I attacks no time
on the clock now we have to assume I
wanted to make the recording area bit
bit smaller but this is not possible by
recording okay we have a green stem bed
type of position where I enjoy the
center edge and the bishop power very
nice position can be easily strengthened
you should for coming
the question is how to get out here why
does obviously in good shape but he has
a very sturdy structure so normally you
need some for this is so surprising oh
yeah this is even more than surprising
it's just bad let's see I can even
consider g4g 45 pinning the night or and
it's a attacking the the pin night yeah
I could have taken the look but the
bishop is so nice only six
going for Bishop rock g-form no it
wasn't into other so dangerous i think
my king is some slightly exposed but
they really no no pieces near it so it's
not a big problem yeah the rukon f8 is
hanging
made i'm still super far behind what the
guy was leading the tournament has
played 10 games what I played for I mean
okay I'm late but but still what did I
forgot even more doubling cubes I can
play some be sick stuff maybe I really
should play in a completely wacky gambit
stop to get in more quick games but it
seems I I cannot catch this guy anyway
this is a bit too much 10 games
yeah they don't really have any quick
winsome system always the problem you
need to not just win but do that as
quickly as possible
yeah very good new good development him
and his played some rather stranger was
like a form
yeah I have the check here this is why
I'm Niger 6am wasn't really a problem
now let's nuts win the night one aged
eight doesn't have any square I could
have also stayed on only three woman
what is wouldn't wouldn't have a bit of
a bad choice mmhmm yeah why can't can I
can do that Knight takes and green g7
that's my deaf too yeah or just Queen
takes a jade yeah Queen takes a jade is
actually much simpler ok go here yeah
maybe even before I became a daddy to do
that before Queenie for check yeah this
is not a quick win anyway ok now i need
to see if i get some other just keep
tournament available to play before 24
you want to take that hmm yeah all that
one it's not bad
King a wonders night before threatening
night situ that's a very annoying check
yeah it's a win but not a quick one if
Eddie just lets the clock run down and
anything better probably not hmm yeah
let's just win this material or the time
turn your head yeah I'm super far behind
we are you very much out of chances need
to win it check the fence 94 here Knight
c3 Bishop e2 as is the known line that's
a bit
Knight c3 Bishop d2 yeah I'll just a
windy for now turn this particular
situation it cannot cancel even I can
just take it someone now we look that c2
hangs but right before yeah are taken
quinium he probably needs 332 C 7 I more
threatening 96 I didn't see that move
when it's not bad well that's a dapper
stupid okay
yeah I couldn't take because of rookie
aid young don't you miss this is a piece
yeah I badly needed the katahajime
resins that kind of mistake maybe I can
can enter the top 10 stone yeah this
helps to place 12 this is not looking
good for black women taking on age 5 is
very very daring month
the Ice King position is very
problematic threatening f 70 f seven and
I text at six taking on g2 is really
greedy it's no wait hopefully I don't
see it lets see one at least yes that's
a mid ah come on so Pete 10 plus 10 but
only one minute left our sixth place
maybe i can get forth with a very cool
okay
yeah this is not too sophisticated but
you know only around 1 minute left I
don't want to exchange Queens in this
situation long castles of Quincy six
unfortunately he he didn't allow that
one of my favorite mates
yeah the Queen sir oops I completely
ignored completely ignored the look da
truth but I was trying to trap the
screen yeah I can go to g5 unfortunately
what the heck do i have used somewhere
how long this tournament is still going
probably not very long jump game aborted
yeah seventh place with nine out of nine
but I started with about nine minutes
late into this tournament let's see if
there's some some other tournament
scheduled so we get a little bit more
action going the daily warzone final in
fact some not too far away it's starting
in 14 minutes and yeah well let's let's
play that and this video will be posted
right right after this little teeth
thanks for watching